اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من الجليل الاعلى
اهلا بكم مع استمرار الغارات الاسرائيليه
على مناطق متفرقه في قطاع غزه اشتباكات
بين المقاومه والجيش الاسرائيلي في محاور
عده بالقطاع وكتائب القسام تعلن تدمير خمس
اليات اسرائيليه في منطقه توام واطراف
مخيم الشاطئ والجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن
ارتفاع عدد القتلى من جنوده في معارك غزه
الى
35 على وقع ازمه انسانيه مستمره وكيل
الامين العام للامم المتحده للشؤون
الانسانيه يقول ان الوضع في قطاع غزه مروع
واستمراره كارثه والمفوض العام لوكاله
الاونروا يطالب بانهاء الحصار على غزه
والسماح للمساعدات الانسانيه بالتدفق الى
القطاع دون
قيود مدير الاستخ اخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه في الدوحه لبحث مفاوضات اطلاق
المحتجزين ونيويورك تايمز تنقل عن مسؤولين
مطلعين على المفاوضات قولهم ان التفاوض
يجري على اطلاق حماس نحو 15 محتجزا مقابل
وقف اسرائيل هجماتها على غزه ثلاثه ايام
ومسؤول اسرائيلي يقول ان اسرائيل مستعده
لوقف القتال اذا رات ان حماسه جاده في
اطلاق سراح
محتجزين ثمانيه شهداء في اقتحام قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لمدينه جنين في الضفه
الغربيه وشهيدان اخران في اقتحام مدينتي
الخليل وبيت لحم ليرتفع العدد الى
173 شهيدا في الضفه الغربيه منذ السابع من
اكتوبر ومواجهات بين فلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اثناء اقتحامها مخيم
الامعري في مدينه رم
الى
اللقاء